you're gonna be absolutely disgusted  after you hear how evil this company is  this company went to poor villages and  towns in pakistan stole their clean  drinking water without paying them a  dime diverted that water into their  factories then they packaged that stolen  water into water bottles and then resold  that water back to the same people they  stole it from and the poor villagers who  couldn't afford these expensive water  bottles they were forced to drink dirty  polluted water and the worst part is  that the plastic bottles they used  didn't even meet health safety standards  who is this evil company you ask it is  none other than nestle nestle makes  everything from the candy you eat to the  food you eat to the food babies eat and  if their water is this bad i wonder what  else they're hiding it turns out they're  hiding a lot of shady stuff so make sure  you subscribe for part 2 of the most  evil company in the world and for more  tutorials on how to be evil